hi everyone i'm jelena a customer
engineer at google cloud
welcome back to the technical series for
startups where we're creating a series
of videos for technical enablement to
help startups to start build and grow
their businesses successfully and
sustainably on google cloud
in the previous video we covered storage
and database portfolio on google cloud
and in this episode we're going to talk
about firebase
our application development platform
in this video we're going to cover
introduction to firebase what common
development problem it solves and what
product it includes after that we're
going to look into what set of services
application developers can use to build
better applications improve their
application quality and engage their
users
we'll go over a customer success story
then we will run through the firebase
console and how to connect an android
app to firebase
and finally we will wrap up with some
resources you can follow up with
so what is firebase firebase is our
mobile development platform that allows
you to quickly build and grow your app
using firebase we provide a set of tools
and cloud services that help mobile and
web developers solve common challenges
across the app lifecycle
from building an app to improving its
quality to increasing user engagement
firebase is easy to integrate on ios
android and the web as well as c plus
and unity to support for game developers
we have a purpose-built sdk for each
popular platform to help you move
quickly and help ensure that your app is
the same quality on every platform after
this short introduction to firebase
let's take a look at a typical
application lifecycle which has three
main phases the first phase is the
development phase when you're developing
a brand new app or adding a new
functionality to an existing app
once your application is ready you want
to share it with your users fun in
control fashion while keeping an eye on
any potential crashes that may happen
finally once your users start enjoying
the new app you want to learn more about
them identify the most valuable users
and decide to further personalize their
experience to retain them
firebase with its comprehensive set of
tools and cloud services helps solve
these three core problems in your
application lifecycle
there are 19 services that are divided
into three categories build better
replication
improve application quality drive user
engagement starting from the left if
you're building a new application
firebase offers a completely serverless
approach to getting started
once the application is built we offer
tools to help you to improve stability
and performance of your application
then finally we have a set of tools to
help you drive user engagement and
retention
let's start with the development phase
category of products
let's take a look at your normal app
architecture something that most of you
probably recognize from your own
projects
you've got your mobile app which
communicates with your main front-end
server using a rest api
that server talks to your all other
backend services
you've probably got a server for
authentication and a server for media
files you also have a database which is
one of the first decisions that app
developers make
you may be concerned about your
infrastructure and how it will grow with
your company
what about if you want to include new
platforms
how would you scale your front-end
server is your authentication server
secure is your media server terabytes
ready and database fast enough
instead of the diagram before here is
what it looks like with firebase
let's build together a mobile app that
process user generated content
it could be a photo album accessible
from both mobile and web interfaces that
detects and extracts from any image
uploaded by the user and presents the
result back to the user the first step
in designing our app architecture is
user authentication
firebase authentication is an out of box
authentication ui that supports email
and password phone authentication
and facebook and many others
now that the user is authenticated they
can upload their image to cloud storage
a secure place in the cloud for user
content
the event of a new image upload to cloud
storage will trigger cloud functions
that in our case will perform optical
character recognition on the image
firebase ml kit makes it easy to access
machine learning models from your app
now that we have extracted the text from
the image we will store it in cloud
firestore a real time nosql database a
client app can subscribe to
notifications of new data being stored
in cloud firestore
and so our users quickly receive a
notification of what text has been
extracted from their image
the user confirms that the text is
indeed correct
if we were building a cloud native app
from scratch we may finish our work here
but what if we're adding a cloud native
module to an existing legacy app that's
running most of its legacy logic on prep
in that case you can simply expose the
secure api to your legacy backend and
utilize cloud functions to notify the
backend every time user approved a new
entry to cloud firestore
now that we covered the benefits of
developing apps with firebase let's talk
about keeping them healthy firebase can
help here too
so you have built your app it's got a
huge list of great features it's doing
well in your alpha test you're sure it's
better than anything out there
but what if your application is buggy or
unstable in the real world
you may receive bad reviews
if your application crashes user may
become unhappy and might leave negative
reviews that scare away potential new
users
what can you do
let's see how firebase can help you too
you have just finished developing a new
feature for your application and you're
ready to publish the updated application
to apple and play stores when rolling
out a new feature you may want to push
it to a small percentage of users first
with firebase you're in full control of
your rollout
first before you upload a new build to
the app stores you can put a new feature
behind the feature flag using remote
config
then using google analytics for firebase
you can select the one percentage of
users who will experience the new
feature first once the one percentage of
users have the new feature enabled you
can use firebase performance monitoring
and clash analytics to monitor user
experience who have new feature enabled
and look for any potential app crashes
that new feature may cause
we can dive more deeply into our data by
exporting it to bigquery soon we'll have
identified that the app only crashes for
the users with very old devices but
works fine on almost 100 of the devices
at this point you may want to exclude
the problematic devices from your
rollout while allowing the vast majority
of your users to enjoy the new feature
finally we have arrived at the perhaps
most critical stage of the application
lifecycle
once the application built with firebase
is out in the world and you know it
performs as expected with all firebase
monitoring dashboards indicating health
you can focus on acquiring and retaining
your most valuable users
first and foremost you need to know your
users with google analytics you can
easily divide your users into audio
segments so you can further personalize
their experience
next with predictions you can utilize
machine learning to predict future user
behavior based on the historical events
captured in analytics
finally if you really need to dive deep
into your data you can mirror all the
events to bigquery
after you understand and start
segmenting your user base it's time to
start experimenting optimizing your
application performance
core to this is remote config that
allows you to remotely change
application behavior without the need to
ship a new build which would be time
consuming and inconvenient for the user
combined with google analytics and a to
b testing you can design and execute
experiments to test what makes the most
optimal app experience for a targeted
segment finally you need tools to help
retain your existing users and acquire
new ones in-app messaging offers push
notifications that pop up in the app to
present your most valuable users with a
special offer for example cloud
messaging will help you reach your users
who haven't visited your app in a few
days to engage them
finally if you're planning a marketing
campaign and you want to advertise your
app on say third party websites dynamic
links will be a great tool dynamic links
will help your prospects locate your app
in their respective app stores
if the user clicks on the link from an
android device they will automatically
land in the play store
while an ios user will be pointed to the
apple store
many customers use firebase to build and
operate their applications one of them
is surfboard payments a swedish based
fintech developing next generation
payment solutions
by downloading their application any
merchant can start accepting electronic
payments in minutes surfboard payments
used firebase in order to be able to
prototype quickly
spot errors by testing before releasing
and sync and store user-generated
content in real time
now let's go over a short demonstration
of how to connect an android app to
firebase
step 1 create a firebase project
in the firebase console click add
project
to create a new project enter the
desired project name
if prompted review and accept the
firebase terms click continue
optional step is to set up google
analytics for your project or use an
existing account and i'm going to use
myanalytics account which i already
created for this demo click create
project
fireplace automatically provisions
resources for your firebase project
when the process is complete you'll be
taken to the overview page for your
firebase project in the firebase console
step 2 register your application with
firebase
go to the firebase console in the center
of the project overview page click the
android icon or add app to launch the
setup workflow enter your app's package
name in the android package name field
click register app
step 3. add firebase configuration file
to add a firebase android configuration
file first click download
googleservices.json file to obtain your
firebase android configuration file in
the second step move your configuration
file into the module app level directory
of your app
in the project level gradle file add
rules to include google services gradle
plugin make sure that you have google's
maven repository as well
in the app level gradle file apply the
google services gradle plugin
step 4. add firebase sdk
using the firebase android bom declare
the dependencies for your firebase
products that you want to use in your
app
declare them in your app level gradle
file
sync your app in order to ensure that
all dependencies have the necessary
versions
and that's it you managed to
successfully add your app to firebase
and this brings us to the end of this
video where we learned that firebase has
an array of offerings that help
developers to work better and faster
to continue to explore what firebase has
to offer in further details check out
our suggestions here and don't forget on
the links in the description
we will see you next time when we will
go over different services and tools for
cacd on google cloud
don't forget to like and subscribe to
our youtube channel click on the bell
icon to get notified each time a new
video is posted
thank you and see you next time
[Music]